the year 2020 has brought light to the
fight for social justice
the padres stand in solidarity with the
black community in the fight against
systemic racism injustice and oppression
players and coaches joined together
holding a black ribbon as a symbol of
solidarity
on the hill getting his first opening
day start for the san diego padres mate
on at first base to get things started
here is david peralta
and a ground ball to first base could be
two hosmer will go to second for one
back to first in time nicely done
three six three of the twin killing two
away
oh it's so nice to see the airtight
infield for san diego the left side
machado tatis how about hosmer being
left-handed he makes sure he catches
that one down on one knee fires the
strike standard madison bumgarner your
diamondback starting pitcher one down
here in the first inning it brings up
andy machado
swinging the minutes and bumgarner
finally gets him
it was tight and it was down got him to
swing over the top two down here in the
first inning brings up tommy fam
[Music]
got it from ted barrett he rings up
machado and gets fans first one out one
on
sharply hit off the globe of hosmer
changes direction into right field
so walker heads to third base
for the diamondbacks bulge hits sharply
and got a glove on the right side before
trickling into right
princeton third one down and carson
kelly
on the ground to shortstop to second for
one on to first for two second double
play two innings
initiated by that man chris paddock
scoreless for petco we'll be keeping an
eye on the paddocks tonight from leander
texas as they enjoy paddocks
opening night start here from san diego
one out machado at first and brings up
jerks and profile
lifts that one high in the air foul
ground third base side carson kelly's
got a beat on it
and he's got it into the screen arson
kelly
harrison able to make the catch right up
against the netting even he has to check
his glove to make sure it stayed in
there cosmo is single to left his first
time up
in the air to right field for hosmer
back goes calhoun on the warning track
in front of the wall to make the catch
at nce bottom of the sixth inning on top
of the order third time true now for
bumgarner
tatis who sends one out to deep right
field calhoun headed back at the wall
that ball is high off the wall heading
for second is tatis and he'll cruise
into second base with a double
and nearly get out of here to right
field almost took it out but it's a one
out double for tatis
they're at the corners now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
gertrude saying it did hit him ted
barrett's saying get back
tingler is going to come out definitely
changes direction but i'm not sure if it
hit the dirt they are going to challenge
this we're going to get a decision right
here
coming back payoff pitch to profar
that is ball four the bases are loaded a
chance here for eric osmer
and a fly ball sent out towards right
center field calhoun going back towards
the wall and that ball is going to be at
one hopper to the wall it'll clear the
bases coming around the scoreboard first
is profile
faces
everybody is running boy that's the big
hit that san diego needed
seventh and a new pitcher emilio began
his
with two ounces gold calhoun
not one right over the middle of the
plate did he get enough cole calhoun
one of the new diamondbacks a home run
off amelia
as mentioned earlier the success
hosner's have at the base is loaded well
that situation is presented to him once
again
osborne drives it to left field peralta
going back and at least can't get it
[Applause]
[Music]
knife we go and is gear into the game
two down for walker runner will take
second of the defensive indifference
fly ball right center grisham on the run
will die but not get it coming around to
score from second is martay myers gets
it in quickly but the diamondbacks gonna
run back
here in the ninth inning it's now seven
to two
and christian walker does a good job he
gets on top of this one and really
doesn't barrel it up
oh
he'll go to first and the padres win
their opener
padres win it seven to two tonight
in fantastic fashion